okay let's try one more bot just to
wrap this one up
and
[Music]
who shall we try this time
okay let's try
let's try danny let's see what happens
there
uh
oh danny benoni
nope
bloom inside
i'm not completely sure this is how i
wanted to play this but
okay at least my bishop gets out there
okay let's castle
let's take that one
i feel better after this move
ah
danny boy
hmm
i think danny is a bit confused about
exchanging material when you're down and
up
that's what i reckon
um
probably i should just get an e4
but you always have the feeling you'll
be cheaper somehow after that
okay what
i once saw dany play
what was it
one minute chess with maxine outside
there in central louise and
that was fun
i have to admit that was good fun
okay come on we should do a good
technique here just swap the bishops now
and
bring some rooks over to the center okay
that's nice so now i can do this
ah tricky
and let's give a
check
and then
very safe h3 and all that oh i'm full of
technique here but
danny missed another trick
okay
and how do we do this
should i
double
should i go knight g4 another rook d4
wait can i go rook d2
yes i can
so
i mean if you get a cheaper you should
make it
[Music]
okay let's see how that ends
oh come on what is wrong with me
i completely forgot about that one
wait
i've got a
i've got a couple of things up my sleeve
so i should be okay let's take that one
let's take that one
and let's go there
and then what's he gonna do knight f4
okay i think i can take that one
okay this must be
another cheapo somewhere in the air
but he's still got the back rank so i
can max this pawn out
get it as far as possible okay let's do
that
and let's do that
okay
so let's go there
and then like the best technicians of
your let's now silently advance that
form
h5
okay let's do g3
king g2
i think is what they all say
the great technical players never rush
probably i might be overdoing it but
anyway
okay if i play a6 he's gonna go what
knight d5 and let's try it
and my big trick
haha
okay
you were testing me dany i thought i was
testing you
anyway i
uh
i think you can have a lot of fun these
um bots seem to have
some personality it's hard to tell how
much they're as tricky as computers but
not so much that they snuffed the life
out of you and i think it is
it's good to play against
something that will make a lot of
mistakes but
still play
tactically accurately
and
it's definitely a very nice training
tool
so um
[Music]
yeah i hope you enjoyed these and there
are many many more bots
i should do maurice next time
but
i'm going to
sign off for now
i'm relieved to have saved it against
myself
it was nice that my bot has no clue how
to win a rook ending
just like me
and
yeah i hope you had fun